This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Dollar Shave Club
Hair is weird.
We have it all over our bodies and we just...
SHORE IT OFF.
What if we could USE it for something OTHER
than... wait...
Hey hairy peeps, Trace here for DNews -- hair
is everywhere.
Heads, legs, arms, backs, butts, feet, faces....
and in the West we really like to shave it
off, which is fine.
It's a personal choice, grooming is important
in ANY society, even insects!
My question is, once you've liberated your
luscious locks from your skin, where does
it go then?
Human hair is mostly made of keratin.
Nature loves this fibrous stuff.
It cover antlers, makes up claws, and protects
shells and hydes -- but in humans we use it
for making hair and the outermost layer of
skin.
The BBC reported in 2010 that 100 grams of
blonde, European human hair was worth as much
as 1,000 pounds sterling!
According to the Hair Price calculator at
HairSellOn.com: 10 inches of regular brown
hair could be worth 80 bucks US!
We use this natural, renewable resource for
a bunch of things already.
It's used for food, construction, vanity,
fashion and art.
Yes, I said food.
Other than keratin, human hair contains L-cysteine
-- a flavor enhancing amino acid.
You might see it on food labels as "dough
conditioner," "reaction flavor" or "E920"
in the U.K..
You could be eating hair in pizza dough and
not even know it!
Darker, straighter hair was easier to extract
the L-cysteine, so most companies used hair
from China and India -- but once word got
out and people got grossed out, now it's taken
from duck feathers or altogether synthetic.
The synthetic version is halal, kosher, and
vegan!
A Chinese company used the amino acids in
human hair to make soy sauce 'til they got
caught...
Mmm!
For something you might find a BIT more palatable...
NASA has been exploring using human hair to
help clean up oil spills.
In 1989, a hairdresser used clippings from
his salon to create a human hair sponge to
soak up the Exxon-Valdez spill off the coast
of Alaska.
The oil clung to the tiny scales in the keratin
and boom!
An oil sponge was born.
Hair is also dead useful in fashion and art.
For example, while doing hair for the movie
Batman Begins, a hairdresser took four-and-a-half
POUND of discarded human hair, and created
a kind-of... natural fiberglass.
Fiberglass is used in all sorts of construction
because it's strong and light, its made of
plastic reinforced with fibers of glass -- in
this case, the glass was replaced by the perfectly
renewable resource -- HUMAN HAIRS.
It has practical purposes for everyday life
too, or... it DID.
Native Americans created human hair twine
and rope by weaving the strong, straight fibers
together -- horsehair was also used.
This is sort of like the oldest use for crafting,
because of course hair is used for wigs, toupees,
beards, eyelashes, you name it -- there's
an industry for making it.
Even... pubic wigs called Merkins.
Weird.
The messed up part about hair, is we just
get rid of it without knowing anything about
it.
Hair, we barely knew thee!
And buying razors is the worst.
They're behind the plastic doors at the convenience
store for some reason and they're expensive.
Do we really need it to vibrate or tell me
the weather or explain Tolstoy?
No.
Dollar Shave Club has come to fix the problem
of the stupid expensive shave.
Their blades shave your happy little faces
just as good as the ones behind the stupid
plastic at the store -- but they'll come right
to you for a few bucks a month; a fraction
of the price.
and Dr. Carver's Easy Shave Butter makes shaving
your face feel like buttering a tasty biscuit.
It's real good.
So how do you feel about hair?
Weirded out?
Or into it?
Have you ever thought about what happens after
it hits the barber's floor?
Tell DNews down below and if you have any
keratin queries check me on twitter @trace501!
See ya.